first in fact by himself at the moment
is ray robson pending the result of the
sam sevillan game ray i know jeffrey's
not exactly in the best of form but
beating him like this is not something
you would expect normally
yeah um yeah i know jeffrey lost i guess
two games in a row so i know he's not
doing his best for sure
but i mean even in those games it felt
like he was
playing decently for a while and then
somehow just uh something went wrong
in this game i think maybe something
went wrong much more
quickly
also i think this is the the first time
i've ever been white against him so i
wasn't really sure what to expect i
played him like a billion times but i've
been black every single game so i didn't
actually like before i started preparing
like
i knew he played like maybe cairo con
but i didn't know like what else he
played as black
interesting uh the opening he played
bishop d6 early on did you expect to see
this move on the board
no yeah of course he completely
surprised me with uh yeah ross lima
bishop b5 then he played e5 and yeah
bishop d6 so i mean i know that this
is an idea i think some strong players
played it maybe magnus played it a few
times
but yeah i couldn't remember i mean i've
looked at it once probably a little bit
but i couldn't remember during the game
any of the ideas so i just came up with
everything over the board so yeah rookie
one was a
probably a good move i mean it's a very
logical move but he started thinking
after this move and it seemed like this
is
was the beginning of um his troubles
maybe so basically i'm just preparing d4
and then if we have a series of captures
on d4 i'll always have the option to
play e5 opening up all my pieces and
um i can get an initiative maybe black
is okay somehow but over the board it
looks very scary so he went for this and
bc so i was really not expecting this d
e i assume i'm just better here
bishop b2 and now if bishop c7 instead
of taking an e5
at minimum i guess i just play e6
and then let's say d takes e6
i can exchange on d8 first or take g7
yeah take take take g7 rook g8 go back
probably to c3 with the bishop and i
assume i'm i'm just better here
so i didn't really understand what his
idea was then he played bishop takes e5
which looked like crazy to me because
after knight takes e5 knight takes
my position looks overwhelming so bishop
takes e5 was like my last idea like i i
was
trying to use the two bishops trying to
like use my leading development so f4 is
the obvious move
um
the line i calculated was f4
knight g6
here after the game you mentioned queen
d6 which maybe is a good move but
my main line was bishop takes g7
rook g8
and now
bishop h6 to protect f4
and now i thought knight d4 at first
and now i thought i should play knight
d2 to control f3
because now in case of knight h4 i can
play g3 safely and f3 is covered and
basically as long as he's not doing
anything immediate uh his position
should be terrible with uh
yeah his lack of development no safe
space for his king
and so i thought this is just great so i
was about to play this then after bishop
h6 suddenly i realized he can play
knight h4
immediately and after g3 because my
knight is still on b1 he has queen f6
and my rook is hanging and also my
bishop and
somehow uh somehow this is just not
working tactically for me
after knight h4 i could play bishop g5
instead
but he'll probably sack
somewhere rook g5 i assumed take take
g3
knight d4
rook a3
um rook b8 and uh this pieces suddenly
are very active and my structure has
been shattered so this looked very
unclear to me like i didn't want to go
for this at all so unfortunately
eventually i kind of had to bail out um
and i took
but i think i'm i'm still better in the
resulting position knight c6 queen c5
should be slightly better but definitely
wasn't expecting um
the game to progress uh as quickly as it
did in my direction rapidly
yeah so this was a another critical
moment um he has a lot of
decisions uh he can go to d6 he can go
to f6 actually those are the only two i
really considered i didn't think king d
could be good because his pieces get
boxed so yeah king d6 is the most
natural to blockade the pawn
and then something like rook b1
and obviously he can never really take
d5 with his king there
and yeah i'm definitely better my rook
is coming to b6
on if he lets me will probably come to
a5 to support the rook on b6
and his king is kind of in danger
although probably i can never just
outright made it with the three pieces
but i'm definitely pressing this was one
option actually i i thought king f6
might be
safer
um and i think he was worried about rook
a3 here which is logical and then i
calculated g6
rook f3 king g7 i bring the rook to the
seventh rank uh he has to play rook f8
now if i if i do nothing he'll get to
play d6 so d6 for me is the logical move
and now i prepare bishop b3
which looks great um the problem is now
he has bishop b7 with tempo because i
open the diagonal and he gets his bishop
out into the game
and it felt like he's surviving this so
unfortunately i probably wasn't going to
be able to play rook a3
um so i probably i wasn't sure i can
play something simple like rook b1
d6 rook b6 rook d8
and something like a5 so i'm definitely
better
but he's definitely resisting and he
still has decent chances to hold this so
um i was expecting king f6 or king d6 in
the game king d8 yeah just seemed like a
big mistake after d6 uh yeah his pieces
are just getting all boxed in the back
rick
and yeah this stage let's say he takes
on b1
um and i take rookie eight
uh there's probably many ways to win but
probably my plan was going to be king f1
let's say rook if rookie 6 rook b6
and
at some point he'll have to move the
rook let's say rookie 5
yeah in that position rook b8
rook c5
uh bishop a6
rook c6 bishop b7 so basically i just
get this construction he has to keep his
rook there now i just bring my king up
because he can't he can only move his
rook so i just bring my king all the way
up to d4 and i think even if i go to the
pawn game and go after his a pawn that's
just winning so he just can't do
anything
and the game i just basically
pushed my pawn i mean all his pieces
were
stuck on the back rank and there are
meeting ideas with rook c8 so
yeah here it's just over
well pretty convincing from your side
you have to make the moves that gives
you the opportunities of course you'll
take them you're in first place at the
moment in the u.s chess championship
after four rounds before rest day have
you ever found yourself in this position
before clear first
in the tournament
well probably after two games i've been
i think i've started 2-0 before
actually that was i think 2016 i think
that was the first time jeffrey played
in the u.s championship and i played him
in the third round
in that game and actually i i felt like
an amazing form in those first two games
and then the night before that game
i got uh like food poisoning
and uh then the next day i had to play
very young jeffrey and he put tons of
pressure on me i had to defend like a
very bad endgame for like 80 moves and
somehow i defended um
and drew but yeah that was probably
maybe the only other time i would have
been in the lead the thing is i'm very
happy with the result um so far like
with my first four pairings i thought
plus two would probably be the best i
could
uh reasonably expect to score or hope to
score um but with the positions i had
i like i could have scored four out of
four um like against sam both of sam sam
sevi and sam shanklin
i had very good chances
maybe it's a bit much to expect to win
both but at least one of two out of two
was very possible unfortunately i didn't
win either of those but yeah very happy
that i i got another win today
and you have yet to play against the big
dogs dominguez wesley so
so certainly the work isn't done yeah
it's very funny pairings like i think
i'm black against all those guys like
i'm black against fabi black against
lanier black against wesley
so it's interesting pairings obviously
if i can
do all my black games then i'll be in
good position but i guess i'll have to
see how they go all right well
congratulations on the day so far get
your rest we'll see you in a couple of
days thanks well done right